una votación electrónica en entredicho
tras 26 años de usar la tecnología en
las elecciones en Brasil el sistema ha
sido atacado por el actual presidente
Jair bolsonaro quien habla de riesgo de
fraude ante los periodistas no quiso
decirse aceptaría o no los resultados de
este domingo
inicial al implementar las máquinas de
votación electrónica fue precisamente
contrarrestar el fraude además ayudó a
que la población analfabeta que son al
menos el 14% de los adultos pudiera
acceder más fácilmente a las urnas en
1996 se usó inicialmente en 57 ciudades
para las elecciones locales tras ser un
éxito en 1998 se implementaron en el 67%
del país y en el año 2000 fueron usadas
a nivel nacional Pero hay opiniones
encontradas acerca de la fiabilidad del
proceso
yo creo que hay un riesgo altísimo de
alteración de los resultados creo que
son riesgo no sé si va a pasar pero las
tecnologías permiten el fraude a
tecnologías electrónicas han demostrado
ser confiables desde hace muchos años
nunca hubo problemas y sobre todo son
importantes en un país del tamaño de
Brasil que tiene dimensiones de un
continente y permiten conocer los
resultados de unas elecciones de más de
156 millones de habitantes en un tiempo
al cerrarse la votación Se envía la
información de las tarjetas electorales
a Brasilia por una red independiente
desde regiones apartadas son enviados
por satélite las máquinas no están
conectadas a internet y el software es
actualizado para cada elección este
sistema ha sido elogiado por Estados
Unidos como un modelo para el mundo pero
Brasil no es el único que utiliza el
voto electrónico otras 22 países lo usan
según el Instituto internacional para la
democracia y la asistencia electoral